c'est grâce à vos parents non non pas du
tout c'est grâce à ma mère de mes
fiertés beaucoup il monte alors on peut
revenir sur ce bail la wii alors moi le
truc c'est que vous en faites
c'est vrai c'est triste à dire mais les
jurys sont complètement prévenu du
moment où ils doivent se retourner pour
avoir fait sauvé je peux vous le dire
c'est qu'en fait avant l'émission
quelques mois avant que je passe aux
additions à l'aveuglé mais avait appelé
il m'avait demandé quel juré j'aurais
préféré avoir d'accord j'ai dit patrick
fiori qui certes on l'est au dernier
moment d'ailleurs patrick fiole et son
calendrier ils sont complètement ça
c'est intéressant ça que florent pagny
en fait sauf et c'est clairement qui je
pense qu'il a été prévenu par la prod du
fait qu'ils ne devaient justement pas se
retourner ça je pense qu'il avait les
boules de quais personnes en fait ce
soir autant l'ex yoplait vous allez vous
discutez la balle et chérie tu voulais
polémique a été tellement vive sur cette
émission là que vianney afin tweets en
disant nous n'avons pas d'oreillette
parce que c'est impossible ce qui s'est
passé très bien et vous le croisez c'est
téléguidé was a boy a décidé lundi d à
laventie ne mentirai pas du goût des
anneaux avec une coiffure comme ça peut
pas mentir non millions dit ça c'est pas
c'est pas possible
bernard montiel qui voulait dire un truc
s'appelle non mais ça lui sinon c'est ce
qui arrive c'est terry mais si c'est
vrai c'est énorme quand même parce que
là on peut comprendre que samedi soir
effectivement ils avaient déjà toutes
leurs équipes composées cetera
effectivement la jeune fille tu as
raison auquel il avait pas d'émotion le
garçon était formidable et peut-être que
tout ça était déjà complet bien que tu
dis ça quand on avait prévenu ou en tout
cas prévenu c'est incroyable c'est pas
la seule anecdote que je connaisse qui
prouve que c'est prévu j'en ai
énormément genre d'actions alors bâti
maintenant parce que la wii si bien en
fait aux battles j'avais du coup une
amie à moi qui était présente lors des
batailles qui accusait la battle qu'on
ne sait plus qui est le prompteur de
nikos avait buggé et en fait elle a lu
merci à tata d'avoir participé à
l'émission etc
alors c'est évidemment qu'elles chantent
et du coup elle a ses têtes ou non en
sachant qu'elle allait perdre et à la
fin elle a perdus et séparés de
l'émission vj la raison d'être des bus
enfin ouais c'est dingue
les meufs ou politique gilles verdez a
souvent raison alors on assure avec sa
tête et sa voix on le croit pas problème
quand vous avez chez vous vous aussi
mais je vais vous dire non mais c'est
vrai lui il arrive et qui dirait on a
imaginé et bon voila mais le gars fait
des bonnes enquêtes mais c'est vraiment
les plus nuls qui gagne aussi quoi il
faut reconnaître que c'est rarement les
plus nuls qui gagnent alors alors